so changing gears a little bit moving on
to rna sequencing library preparation
in this case this is usually done to
look at gene expression
to identify which genes are turned on or
off in a given sample
and most of the times people are really
interested in the protein coding
transcripts or messenger rnas these are
polyadenylated transcripts
but they only make up a small portion of
the total amount of rna
most of the rna is made up of ribosomal
rna
and this is generally things that are
undesirable that people don't want to
sequence and waste their sequencing
dollars
and so to prepare rna sequencing
libraries there are a couple of extra
steps
one is a depletion or enrichment step
the second
is conversion of rna to dna because the
illuminate sequencers only work for dna
you can't sequence rna directly on these
platforms
and then the last step again is to add
sequencing adapters
to complete the dna library preparation
of that converted rna and i'm going to
go over two methods today
the truseq style library prep method for
rna and also a method called smartseek
but there are many many other types of
library preparation for rna we just
don't have time to go over
all of them in this talk
so first we have to do some rna
enrichment to select for
the polyadenylated messenger rna
transcripts and there are two methods to
do this the first method
is to take advantage of the fact that
messenger rna has
a poly a tail on the through prime end
and we can use a poly a capture
technique
that uses beads that have oligo dt on
the surface
and these beads are able to capture the
messenger rna
through this interaction with the polya
tails these can be washed
and so that the ribosomal rnas are
are washed away and then you elute the
poly a
messenger rna from the beats and go
through library preparation
a second method is instead of capturing
poly rna you can deplete ribosomal rna
and there are a couple different methods
of doing this but the most common method
right now
is using a probe a dna panel of probes
that
will bind to your messenger that will
bind to your ribosomal rnas
that also have a biotin handle on the
end so you go through a hybridization
reaction where these probes will bind to
ribosomal rna but not bind to poly a
rna and then use magnetic beads to pull
these out
of the solution and you're left with
poly a
messenger rna in your tube that you can
go through library preparation
[Music]
so with the truseq sample preparation
what you do is you take your rich rna
and then you fragment that rna into
small bits that are appropriately sized
for luminous sequencing
and then you prime them so that you can
undergo a reverse transcription reaction
reverse transcription is a process where
you take
rna and then use primers and a reverse
transcriptase
enzyme to generate a cdna copy
of that rna after this process you have
single stranded dna and you go through a
process called second strand synthesis
so that you convert your single
single-stranded dna
into a double-stranded dna that can go
into
library preparation so once you have
your double-stranded library
or your double-stranded dna that
originally came from rna you can go
through that truseq sample dna
preparation that we went over earlier
to generate a sequencing library
[Music]
the next method of rna library
preparation that we'll go over
is called smart seek and this uses some
of the same enzymes as the true siccon
rna and preparation
but it has one advantage in that you
don't have to do
a rna enrichment step and this is
because the reverse transcription
reaction
is primed by a oligodt
and so this will again only bind to your
messenger rnas that have these poly a
tails at the end
and you go through this reverse
transcription reaction and so it'll make
this copy
of dna using rna as a template
one special thing about this process is
that it uses a root transcriptase that
has
a template switching activity it'll add
a couple of non-templated c
bases at the end of the cdna and this
will allow a template switch oligo
that's also present in the reaction
that contains a couple of g bases so
these g bases can hybridize on to those
t
those c bases that got added by the
roots transcriptase
and then the roof transcriptase will use
this template switch oligo
as a template and it'll continue the
reverse transcription reaction
so that you wind up with a tag cdna that
has
handles on both ends depicted in green
here this cdna can now be amplified
and many copies can be made and then
this can go
into a library preparation using either
your truseq style dna library prep or
your nextera library preparation methods
to generate
a library
so with sample preparation you a lot of
times are not working with just a single
sample you're working with many samples
for instance if you want to compare the
transcriptional profiles of
treated and untreated sample or healthy
and diseased you have several different
samples that you want to sequence
together
and it can be really inefficient if each
of those samples goes on to their own
sequencing reaction because it can cost
a lot of money
one thing that you can do with these
illumina sequencing libraries is
within those adapters get added to the
ends of your inserts
you can have different barcode sequences
so that each sample gets a unique
barcode
and that's depicted over here so let's
say we have a sample
that's already bound to the flow cell so
it's already attached to the surface
the adapters are here and here
we can add two different barcodes or
index sequences
onto these illumina libraries they're
called the i7
and the i5 sequences and again these can
be unique
for each different sample that you
repair and these can be pulled together
and run on the single sequencing run and
so during the sequencing process
what happens is you the first read that
you do
is the insert read for read one after
you've done that you can strip that away
and then you can add on a sequencing
primer to read this i7
index so that'll hybridize on and then
you can do a couple sequencing cycles
so that you get the barcode sequence for
this molecule
next you flip the templates around
so that this template becomes flipped
and then bound on to the
flow cell so if you switch your
orientation and then
you can sequence the second index with a
couple of cycles
and then after that's done you can strip
that away and then sequence your other
end of your insert
and you can link all of these sequences
together so
your insert reads and your barcode reads
because they're all constrained to the
same area of that flow cell
and then you can use those barcode
sequences to separate your reads
into your different sample pools so
again you're healthier disease you're
treated you're untreated
you